right good uh morning members
um Charles will be starting the stream
yeah
just one second we are just uh with the
live stream on
well yes
it's morning somewhere in the world um
Council Auburn
we have our own time clocking than it
didn't you know that yeah
good morning good morning members we are
now live on the live stream and welcome
to this um GPC meeting on the 4th of
November
just some housekeeping fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated vacate the offices by the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
would everyone Pleasant please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress officers in attendance
Sonja Godfrey HR manager fion pepper HR
business partner and
Hannah Thorpe head of communications
we have apologies for from councilor
Everett and councilor Stuart Piper I
don't believe there are any other
absences
does anyone had any interest to declare
any items of business on the agenda for
this morning this afternoon sorry
Charles
item three minutes of previous meetings
to approve the minutes of the meeting
for the general purpose committee held
on the 12th of May 2022 a copy is
attached to the agenda pack please can I
have a proposer and secondary proposer
councilor David Saunders a secondary
councilor Trisha Austin
do members agree
what I'm just uh
do we have two meetings or was there
sorry one second I just uh
so I mean it's approved oh it does say
fifth of July but the minutes were
actually for the
5th of July
sorry my script is incorrect it's uh the
meeting notes are correct my script is
incorrect
okay sorry so perhaps I'm going to do
that again to approve the minutes for
the meeting on the 5th of held on the
5th of July can I have a proposal in a
second account sir David Saunders second
attrition Council Fisher Austin do
members agree thank you for pointing
that out councilor bayford
top of the class of paying attention
so we move on to item four
item four is the HR policy review phase
one
to introduce
um
fion pepper I believe are you
introducing always Sonia are you
introducing
yes okay sorry Sonia if you'd like to
introduce the the item
foreign
good afternoon everyone
um the purpose obviously of this meeting
is to provide an overview of some key HR
draft policies and to seek approval from
yourselves so we can Implement these
um policies into the council as you'll
be aware the council disbanded its
shared HR provision back in September 21
and transferred HR back in-house
um HR in house has afforded us the
opportunity to review and update a
number of HR processes and policies as
such HR has progressed the review of a
number of key policies in line with best
practice and to better support the
council managers and staff in the
application of these policies
um in preparation for this meeting you
will have received a copy of the revised
draft policies all of which have gone
through a robust consultation process
with both our unions a corporate
management team and staff and I will
hand over to fee he'll provide a high
level overview on some of these key
draft HR policies
thank you
thanks good afternoon everybody so
rather than go through kind of the
details of each policy I thought it
would be helpful just to give you an
overview of the key changes that we've
made and so in most cases the policies
and procedures have been combined into
one document so with our current
policies we have a policy a procedure
and then we quite often have a set of
guidance notes for managers a set of
guidance notes for staff and there's
different points covered in each one so
it becomes quite difficult to kind of
for managers particularly to work out
which document they should be looking at
so we've put them all into one document
so it's a little bit longer but actually
is much more clear in terms of the
process to follow
um again with most of the policies we've
introduced a key points section
um so this
um sits at the stop the top of each
policy and just highlights the main
points of interest the main reasons why
you might pick that policy up um and the
kind of areas that it's used for so that
you know you're looking at the right
policy without having to go through all
of that detail
um first of all
we've introduced a section in each
policy around the right for staff to be
accompanied by unions or by a workplace
colleague because that's been an area
that has caused some confusion in the
past so that's just a clarification for
all parties
um in our current policies the
disciplinary procedure is used for the
formal stages of absence management
Performance Management and some other
substantial reason
that also has caused
um not not issues but I think
um particularly when you're dealing with
an absence case someone who's got a
long-term sickness having to then follow
a disciplinary procedure to sort of move
them to ill health retirement for
example is quite
um can be quite distressing for them
because disciplinary is traditionally
associated with misconduct so we've now
put a specific procedure into each
policy so it follows the same process
but it's specifically refers to that
policy and the reason why you're in that
stage
um the what was previously the dignity
at work policy has been retitled to the
bullying and harassment policy
dignity at work kind of almost said what
it did on the tin but not quite as
clearly as bullying harassment so it was
just a simplification in terms of title
um in both that policy and the grievance
policy we've introduced a section around
how we'll deal with complaints and
grievances that are deemed to be
malicious or vexatious so this is
something that's been an issue
um
over the years it's something that's
covered in the
um agreements procedure for statutory
officers so felt that it was appropriate
to to deal with other staff in the same
way to give them the same
um take the same approach
it was
um an area of concern for the trade
unions in particular and so we've talked
at length with them and agreed exactly
the process and the wording in the
policy and how we'll approach that with
them
um the whistleblowing policy we've
expanded on what is and isn't
uh classified as a whistleblowing
complaint and as well as being reviewed
by the section 151 and the monitoring
officer the policy has also been
reviewed by external employment lawyers
to make sure that it's clear and that
points of support
um are detailed clearly within the
policy so that people know where to go
if they have a complaint that they want
to raise as whistle blow
um the final point is that we've tried
to be a little bit less prescriptive
about how managers handle the informal
stage of procedures so at the moment we
have specific forms that have to be
filled in as the informal stage and that
causes some confusion between whether
it's actually informal or formal because
you're formally writing it down on a on
a document and can cause issues if it's
not been filled in or managers have
chosen to take a slightly different
approach
um so we've got a form if managers want
a template we've got that available but
if they don't then we're quite
comfortable that they can handle that as
they see fit depending on the
circumstances of the case
so I think those are the key points that
I think we need to cover but obviously
happy to take any questions about
specifics
thank you
um I'd just like to say
um thank you for this document because
it is far Advanced on the procedures
that were in place prior and I think um
congratulations should go to the team
for putting together this document and
it is very well laid out and easy to
follow so
um if you could pass that on to all
that's involved I'm sure that members
agree that this is a very necessary
document and obviously
um it's a risen out of the section 24
um report that came and it was this was
main part of uh the Crux of of what was
deemed to be so our governance issues
and and um employment issues so um
congratulations to the team uh members
have got any questions so I have hands
up from Council Auburn and then Council
Austin Council Auburn yes thank you
chair uh and and again I I thoroughly
support with what you've just said I
think uh certainly from my point of view
the shared service it was an absolute
failure in my in my opinion
and a lot of the problems that we've
gone through recently been due to that
um as as my former colleagues sitting
there will know that we had a quite a
robust individual
process for each of these issues
prior to the prior to the
um
foreign
service so um I'm very pleased that this
is that this is here chair
um
the only kind of issue that that I have
is if you're just talking about the
grievance uh
procedure and I think the the difficulty
that you've got here is that when you
have the informal process
which is a good thing you should be able
to to get people together to talk about
what those issues are you know if
they're if you know
educated you should be able to sit down
and you should be able to talk about the
issues that you have with another
colleague or whatever but because it's
informal you can't make them come
together
so that's where the difficulty lies with
with the informal process and then you
you alternate then to go through the
formal process which can be long and can
be difficult
um
so I mean that's just one thing that
that's just a minor thing but I think a
bit of thought has to go into the
informal process of the grievance is to
how to get people together in dealing
with it and hopefully that that the vast
majority of any grievances that our
staff would have will be dealt with
during an informal process which saves
everybody a lot of time and a lot of
grief so I think that I would just ask
if you know
uh that that could be looked at maybe a
little bit a little bit more in depth of
the informal process thank you chair
you Council Robin yeah um obviously take
that away and then we can report back on
that
um it's quite hard to uh how to
regularize informal because then it
becomes formal but like you rightly say
it's um it's a gray area but um things
can be sorted out informally then it can
save a lot of heartache and pain for
absolutely everybody maybe a whip and a
chair that could help you know but uh
yep okay so that's Julie noted uh
Council Auburn um councilor Austin
thank you chair and thank you very much
for this the the the the way that it's
all set out the clarity and whatever is
is exemplary it's wonderful
um I've got one suggestion about the
bullying harassment policy and a few
questions about the absence if I may uh
The Bullying enhancement in the
disciplinary policy and procedure
there's a specific line about managers
leading by example and I wonder if we
could have something similar in the
bullying harassment policy in the light
of some of the comments that we've had
externally about that there's there's
quite a a good line in it about
respectful behavior and I wondered if we
could put something in to the manager's
guidance about managers modeling
respectful behavior in their work with
colleagues it just feels to me like it's
something that we could do to reinforce
and I know most of our managers know
this but just in terms of of people
coming in and so on just stressing that
that is part of our expectation of
managers at whatever level in the
organization feels to me like it would
be beneficial
um the absence one
it felt to me I don't know how to say
this it links with what you were saying
Finn about
um the the way that the disciplinary
process was used in in long-term absence
Etc it feels still feels to me a bit
disciplinary some of the lines at the
beginning about
um you know going to a hearing and
whatever it just feels a bit
I would like it I would like the tone of
it to feel a little bit less
about the term terms like hearing feel
to me rather than say meeting feel to me
a bit a bit
as if we're already saying we think that
somebody's swinging the lead or the the
use of the term cooperate cooperate it
we expect employees to cooperate
something rather than participate in
something just some of the terminology
just feels to me a whip a bit
a bit disciplinary that's all I can say
you know a
not as open not as supportive as perhaps
we might want it to be
I don't I mean I'm not an HR
professional and obviously and you know
I'll I'll take your advice on it but it
just felt to me particularly those first
couple of lines about
um right at the beginning with the in
the in the um in the key points about
the outcome may be or whatever you know
just something that says you know in
some circumstances this might or that
that kind of a thing to
to soften it I think if I was a new
employee reading this I'd think oh
I think we can we can look at that I
think the difficulty is with a formal
process if we're looking at potential
dismissal there are certain things of
course I just wonder if if it needs to
be in the key points the moment you open
the document because it's there quite
clearly later on
and whether we can just have
um you know first absence review second
absence review and we can use the term
review or meeting or or whatever rather
than hearing we can use the term
participate rather than cooperate it
just feels to me like that would be more
encouraging of positive participation by
employees
yeah we can have a look at it
yeah it's it's just the it's the
formality I know I know the difficulties
I know it's a yeah I appreciate it it's
just managing expectations at the point
you're at that you know that level of
having a discussion around your absence
yes it does become and it obviously it
does become formal yes I think it's more
around managing expectations between the
manager and the employee yeah to
understand you know where they are in
that process yeah um so absolutely we
would look to obviously manage things
you know yes informally but obviously
yes I think maybe just a bit more
positive terminology early on in the
document might just and then it becomes
clear later on but obviously if there's
an issue then it has to be formal and it
has to follow follow uh the the the
formal guidelines but earlier on in the
document it will be nice to see it
feeling a bit more Collegiate yeah okay
um and I wanted to ask also about
um the following up of very short-term
absence so one day absence and you know
that um you know somebody goes home at
lunchtime with a migraine or whatever
whether we whether obviously we expect a
manager to know whether the person's
back at work and so on but are we saying
they can't just send them a text saying
how are you feeling now are you back in
in the office or whatever whether we're
expecting them to phone
every time under every circumstance
yeah yep okay that's fair enough
yep
in operational services for instance
where they start very early if it's if
it's more time efficient I suppose to
send a text initially and follow up with
a phone call that might be a slightly
different arrangement but yeah
absolutely
chair I wanted to ask one more question
more generally about the way that we're
approaching this are we
saying that we are maintaining our
previous stance that there is no member
involvement at all in any of this even
in appeals even for senior staff I know
this isn't statutory officers but is
that is that the general way that we're
going with this
now the the purpose of this document
obviously is for the management of all
the staff which is not an issue for
members
um other than the statutory officers
we're not
um either responsible or uh if you like
it it is not within our jurisdiction
this this paper is purely bought to the
GPC because the GPC now since we bought
the um and correct me if I if I'm wrong
with this terminology but since the HR
function has been bought in-house GPC is
a recognized committee
to be that if you like the interface
between the operational Services of the
staff and the members so our
jurisdiction is purely to ensure that
the procedures are in place and
obviously they are followed by but that
is that is the ultimate role of the
header paid service so this is just um
if you like an advisory document of how
the head of paid service and the HR
function perform within the staff it's
not within our jurisdiction to we can
ask for maybe
consideration for certain parts of it
but it is not our document and it is not
under our jurisdiction so I believe
that's uh the correct way of putting it
something I would like to add as well
this document is not only here to
protect the staff of the council he's
here to protect the council
because that is ultimately what you have
to remember if you wear
a hat like I used to wear in my role in
my previous life was the fact that the
document is for both parties and
um the better the document the better
protected both the corporation are and
the staff are
um so that is key to remember and we
also must remember although
um
I mean these offices are the HR experts
I'm certainly not an HR expert and
probably don't ever wish to be to be
honest um but uh it's uh it's um
we must we must follow procedures that
are long tried and tested
especially regarding absenteeism because
we have to protect the corporation as
well as protect the staff but it has to
remain balanced so
um and the terminology would be that in
I would imagine that if you go to the
next stage of process that you've
actually you've you've actually had a
framework in which you've worked with
previously so watering things down
terminology wise is is not necessarily a
good thing yeah you know if you make it
too pink and fluffy then that exposes
either both the corporation or in this
case the council and the staff because
you you get into too many gray areas so
um that's why I believe the terminology
is such I mean it would be legally
um sound to to use that terminology so
um but uh if you can um just follow up
on what I basically said about what our
role in is in this it's basically just
to ensure that the operational side if
you like of the council and and the and
the
um the Staffing side is is being run in
correct governance
um but we don't have any jurisdiction on
that
I mean it was basically following up on
what you've said and you know a sort of
against in Hawaii
um cash roster in this point
um you know because I I think that those
words to me don't seem particularly
harsh and if we're judging this by the
response of a new Joiner who goes
straight to the policies and thumbs
through them and then takes offense at
the wording of their sort of second
sickness absence then perhaps you've got
the wrong member of Staff rather than
the wrong HR policy
yeah I think it's um I mean I don't
think I read I I think I work for my
company for 25 years and I actually
didn't never read my terms and
conditions um I just uh
uh who did I would hate to think um I
never even bothered to to pay attention
when I got when I got a pay rise either
so there was obviously something wrong
with me but uh Council
um I think both yourself and councilor
Beaufort have
snatch my question my answer I I do
believe that you need a strong policy
because
what the workforce do if if it's weak
the workforce will take advantage of it
um and it is what it is it's discipline
it's not touchy feely it it has to be a
discipline
through and through thank you
Council album is there yes thank you
chair um I think um
I think what we've
almost here
uh and just go back to what council
Austin said about the wording of the
document is that both the trade unions
and the staff themselves are happy with
what is in the policy and I think that's
the important thing as far as I'm
concerned I don't think it needs
changing
um you know at the end of the day
the staff will read it they'll know what
it means you know and if they're not
unsure about it they can go to these
kind people here who would who will
explain it to them
um
and um just a question I know you don't
have to
but have you is this these policies been
kind of run past acas at all just
just to see if you're hunky-dory
that's a good point now um has it and I
was going to say they they're obviously
in line with best practice they're in
line with acass um guidance and we've
also talked to our other colleagues in
the Kent region as well and obviously
look to other organization policies so
we are you know we're very robust in
what it is that we've put forward to
ourselves absolutely as you've said we
have consulted um with both unions
Senior Management and staff and we've
taken on board all comments um to make
sure the policies are robust so we can
effectively manage the organization
um going forward from a HR perspective
I'd also like to say that we since
coming back in-house we are actively
working with managers to ensure
um that matters HR matters are being
dealt with appropriately with managers
and we have a complete handle of of all
cases that are going on things like
absence so we are working with managers
and making sure that they have upskilled
appropriately to support them with these
policies
thank you
yes you can so the short answer was now
then
show as long as you're happy and uh but
the short answer was no you haven't run
it past akas but I heard what I heard
what you said and so as long as they're
as long as you've got your handle on it
that your hand on the handle then that's
fine the policies are in line with all
acasts guidance so okay I'm satisfied
with how they look and how they would be
implemented
I assume what you're asking is would we
seek akas's endorsement to our policy
would that be would that be a practice
anyway would we go to our class and say
this is our policy are you happy with it
I mean that presumably isn't that
because it's our job to make sure that
we're in line with them rather than them
in line with us so um and maybe probably
wouldn't want to do the work anyway so I
would imagine that would be the right
way around but uh
that's what I said to you they don't
have to but I was just asking if they
had that result
maybe acas need to consider a star badge
for for policy or something I don't know
but I wouldn't think that they would
it is that way round isn't it we they
they make sure that that
we have to follow their guidelines and
um and that's ultimately what's been
happening what's happened here so um the
answer to David Saunders thank you chair
um I think like all policies Council
Auburn there's a degree of plagiarism
involved in order that you do cover all
your bases
um I'd just like to thank
um the officers for the work that
they've done
um I really wish these documents were in
place two years ago because some of the
members of the panel here have been
involved over the last 18 months where
we've been looking at uh legal speak
and a lot of this is easily read and in
plain English which is appreciated and
I'm sure if we have disciplinary
situations to investigate in the future
this is a much better document as a
reference point so I'd like to thank you
thank you
thank you um I have some questions if I
may as
it's not his chair but as a member of
the panel
um
is there I mean I might have missed it
so forgive me but um definition of short
versus long
um absenteeism
is is there a definition you know uh
um and
um
page fifth on 15 2.1 it says the
arrangements are for
um the chief the chief executive and the
151 and the and the monitoring officer
are outside obviously of this are those
around those arrangements are I believe
in place because we put the procedures
through the GPC before but I just wanted
to clarify that because I didn't want
um a hole between
the non-statch tree and the statutory
staff which I think we have experienced
in the past so just to make sure that
you refer to
um
sorry forget forgive me what did I say
page 15. so 2.1
um the policy and procedures applies to
all employees of foundation accounts
with the exceptions of the chief
executive the section 151 and monitoring
officer for whom separate Arrangements
apply
and those within the probation period so
um
is is that in place and just to confirm
that that is actually in place on that
side of things
um I believe it is but I just wanted to
clarify that
um
and
yeah sure
so just in terms of uh sickness absence
durations so long-term sickness is
anything that's uh in excess of two
weeks or ten ten working days so
anything up until that point would be
short term anything from that point
onwards is long term
um in terms of uh statutory offices so
in theory it would be covered by the
um kind of the disciplinary
stage for statutory officers but I think
there is some work to do to put a
specific policy in place there so we've
got the obviously the procedure for
grievance for statutory offices I think
there is some work to do on the other
elements so they're covered by there is
a process but I think it would be good
to do a piece of work to clarify that in
a separate document in the same way
we've got in terms of grievance so
that's on the sort of to-do list as such
um so Annex 2
um sorry this isn't fundamental but
there's on 5.5 there's a format slit but
I just thought you might want to log
that
um
sorry it's the auditor coming out of me
I apologize
um on the formal procedure
um
the
I mean I know we've referred to not
having forms in the informal procedure
but in the formal procedure
um
would it help to have a a specific form
that could be logged the only reason I'm
saying that is because through past
experiences
things that came in were never
officially logged and it was very hard
when we were referring back to there was
a lot of he said she said he said she
said so I wondered whether or not for
the formal procedure bit
whether even if it was an aid Memoir
that could be logged and then obviously
kept for anything future
um
and on that
sorry 10.3 on that one was um an
official form so that's really what
so it says that the manager receiving a
complaint person considering most cases
for any reason not appropriate the
managing receipt of the complaint would
contact HR
so that point is a sort of trigger and I
just wonder whether or not it would be
easier to have like an official form
that it follows through procedure
um the only other bit that
and um again it comes back to counselors
saunders's point was that
I was quite interested to to understand
the definition of whistleblowing
because in
and in the whistleblowing section
um it does say report to director Mo or
151 there's no reference to the chief
executor head of paid service is that is
that deliberate is that because the
whistleblowing doesn't go to the header
paid service
or is that just a mission
um
under the scope
then on the definition
um obviously the definition of the
whistleblowing bullying is not listed
and then it goes on to refer to bullying
is part of the harassment policy
so
um
but um obviously how I word this but
prior to this was bullying only able to
come in Via a whistleblowing
root or should it at that should any
bullying prior to this coming into Force
should it have come in through the
bullying and harassment policy
so if I go back to the
formal procedure and the form I think
that we can pick that up as part of that
would be kind of an internal process as
opposed to part of policy so you
absolutely we can make a note about that
um the in terms of the head of paid
service whistleblowns generally only
refers to section 151 a monitoring
officer in terms of
um statutory officers so that's why
we've left it like that that was
reviewed by employment lawyers and they
were comfortable with that
um
and the final point
oh bullying harassment so bullying
investment was always covered by the
Dignity of work policy so that policy
always existed I think we've had some
issues where it's been confused with
whistleblowing and that's where we've
tried to
um clarify in the whistleblown policy so
if it's an issue that's personal to you
a bullying and harassment claim
complaint that's personal to you that
would be followed you'd follow the
bullying harassment policy and not
whistleblowing you would only become a
whistle-blowing issue if it has a wider
kind of public interest and that's what
we've tried to explain and we've put in
the bit around seeking advice from the
section 151 or the mo if you've got
specific concerns around that and they
need to clarify
yeah I think that's really important
because
um that you know whistleblowing is a
specific
um process and it Bears more weight in
in eventual legal proceedings than maybe
an internal policy so that's why
um so I think that that clarification is
probably needs a sort of bit of
underlining if you like so uh maybe it's
just it's a case of managers
understanding that if they're in receipt
of it then
um
to know that it's very specific I mean
whistleblown is very specific and it's
mainly therefore
the points that are raised as opposed to
an internal harassment or bullying
process yeah so I just wanted to clarify
that so thank you very much but again
you know this is a excellent document
even I could follow it so that's good
cancer Auburn yeah just a question to
follow on what you're saying
um
so if we've got someone's being bullied
since I managers bullying a member
member of Staff but the member of Staff
doesn't report The Bullying but somebody
sees it and wants to whistle blow on it
how does that does that not come in as
whistleblowing in or is that because
that is effectively whistleblowing is it
not
sorry to throw you a curveball
turn your mic off some of us
um
it is but I think the way we would deal
with it would be different I think we
would investigate it as a bullying
harassment complaint as opposed to
treating it so they may
they may raise it as a whistleblown but
I think the way we would deal with it is
through bullying and harassment policy I
think it would still be it's about an
individual issue as opposed to
an issue of a culture yeah yeah okay
counts rosting
thank you chair can I just come back on
on the matter of use of language I was
not in any way wishing to suggest that
we water anything down but I do think
we've got some great examples of
positive language here I'm looking at
the Performance Management uh section
for example which starts with we strive
to ensure through our policies that
staff can deliver excellence in all they
do we want to find ways of working
together Etc and it was that kind of
feel that I was trying to get in the in
the uh in the sickness one more of a a
Cooperative you know we're all here to
to work together on it and so on just in
terms not in terms of any way changing
the uh terms of it but in terms of
looking at the way that it feels the way
that it reads the the the the positivity
of the language which I think is
exemplary in this um Performance
Management policy and I'd like to see
something that feels a little bit more
like that in the absence that was all
thank you
a handful
thank you yeah just to say I think the
point now is that we're at the stage
where the the documents are pretty much
good to go having gone through quite a
lengthy detailed process of consultation
just to give my reassurances around this
obviously HR we're going to be doing a
whole rollout of this
um to staff and as part of that that is
ensuring that managers and staff are
fully
um aware of the policies that exist what
it means to them they have been part of
this whole process up to this point
anyway so it shouldn't be anything
that's new and obviously the way in
which that's framed will be a bit more
con that will be the softer stuff that
will be more supportive so I think
absolutely we we hear what you're saying
and I think you're exactly right it's
got to be pitched in a way that is
supportive of staff and but our
recommendation would be that the
language that's used within the document
has been picked for a particular reason
and but I think that the messaging
around that we can we can absolutely
take that on board
okay members are not anymore
questions so um
so members I'm asking uh that we um
adopt the revised HR policies with
effect from the first December 2022
do I have a second up councilor Bob
bayford
um do members agree if you like a show
of hands I think that's foul
it's a unanimous thank you Charles
that is carried so thank you members it
concludes the business for this meeting
and I declare the meeting closed at
12 41.
thank you very much